everybody wants to hang out with the the
silverback man
everybody wants to hang out with the guy
who's knocking people out take a point
huh yeah i bet your boys going through
that right now
who's that dustin oh yeah i'm sure
oh i know he's been hacked yeah people
have been trying to get him to do
everything he said stop
yeah driving gloves he said somebody hit
him up to model driving gloves i'm like
jesus man
for golf huh no for driving autos bro
like
like the taxi kept driving like new york
like roaring 20s kind of [ __ ]
whenever i get into a tax cab the guy
had gloves i was like bro we're about to
be early
this guy can't ready to
work bro who's playing
dude how strenuous is holding the wheel
we got power steering now dude
people drive with their knees dude
people who have no
arms and they go to work by driving with
their
[ __ ] feet and you got full on gloves
to hold the wheel the wheel is made out
of gloves
they made it easier for you they just
put the glove on the wheel
it's unbelievable what could it possibly
do
i don't know after a long day drive you
think you take it off you're like thank
god
i pour i'm sweating through he's in the
laundry
but i think they're waiting to help you
like get like
no he's wearing weighted driving have
you [ __ ]
seen america talk people are wearing
complete [ __ ] there was a weighted
swimming
neck brace that two people [ __ ]
drowned in that they had a lawsuit like
eight years ago
why would anybody yeah dude wear weights
in the pool because they're [ __ ]
idiots here
have you been alive have you [ __ ]
been outside of your eyes
no people are [ __ ] bro
awaited swimming to fight people are
legally [ __ ]
and then there's people that are just
after that yo that's the thing that's
crazy
is it like we have to decide when a
[ __ ] starts right and there are people
who are
just not recording yeah we call them
normal dude there's
no that yeah that first the first little
iq point right
there those people walking around barely
getting by
yeah like every once in a while want to
make one of the moans
and little [ __ ] jurassic park
there is a guy okay alan his parents
just
let him go outside and just [ __ ] turn
around and just look at each other
just
they gotta hold in that [ __ ] sound so
nobody knows
they gotta hold that [ __ ] out yeah just
look at her
[Music]
it's like a mosquito
yeah dude that's like a mosquito dude
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one
you